THERE, DOESN’T IT?
MAN O OSPACE O MAN:  ABSENCE FRO
CORONAVIRUS PHONE CALLS WITH
GOVERNORS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> THE INTENTION WAS NEVER FOR
THE WEEKLY CALL, THE COVID CALL
THAT IS LED BY OUR COVID
COORDINATOR TO BE A PART -- FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO BE LEADING THAT
CALL.
THE INTENTION WAS FOR OUR COVID
COORDINATOR TO BE PROVIDING AN
UPDATE DIRECTLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, GOVERNORS HEAR
QUITE A GREAT DEAL FROM THE
PRESIDENT ON HIS PLANS TO GET
THE PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL.
STEVE: BUT, DESPITE WHAT SHE
SAYS, SOME STATE LEADERS
INCLUDING OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS
THAT IS REALLY NOT ENOUGH AND
CALLING TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
NEBRASKA GOVERNOR PETE RICKETTS
JOINS US RIGHT NOW FROM OMAHA.
HEY, GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON.
STEVE: GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
SO I THINK VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS HAS BEEN ON THE PHONE
CALL ONCE DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION.
JOE BIDEN NEVER HAS BEEN.
WHEN THE CALL WAS BEING MADE,
THE COVID CALL DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, HOW OFTEN WAS
MIKE PENCE OR THE PRESIDENT ON
THE LINE?
>> SO, YOU IN THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION, THERE WERE 40
WEEKLY CALLS ABOUT THE PANDEMIC,
MIKE PENCE CHAIRED 39 OF THOSE,
WHICH MEANS HE WAS ON THE ENTIRE
TIME ANSWERING QUESTIONS FROM
GOVERNORS, FIELDING THOSE
QUESTIONS.
SOMETIMES THESE WOULD LAST A
COUPLE OF HOURS LONG AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP JOINED US FOR 8
OF THOSE PHONE CALLS WHICH IS IN
STARK CONTRAST TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHERE THE CALLS
LAST ABOUT 45 MINUTES, AND VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS HAS BEEN ON
ONCE FOR ABOUT 5 MINUTES.
SHE DIDN’T TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
STEVE: RIGHT.
>> IT REALLY SHOWS THE
DIFFERENCE IN APPROACH OF THE
WHITE HOUSE RIGHT NOW IN HOW
THEY REALLY DON’T APPRECIATE THE
WORK THE GOVERNORS ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATES WHERE WE
ARE ON THE FRONTLINE.
AND REALLY SHOWS A LACK OF
LEADERSHIP ON THE PART OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
STEVE: I KNOW YOU FEEL THAT THIS
IS NOT THE BIPARTISAN APPROACH
TO THE COVID CALL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THE INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION HAD PROMISED YOU.
BUT, ULTIMATELY, ARE YOU GETTING
THE SAME KIND OF INFORMATION IN
THIS CALL WHICH I BELIEVE IS
BEING KICKED OFF EVERY WEEK BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
GOVERNOR’S ASSOCIATION, GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO?
>> YEAH, GOVERNOR CUOMO KICKS IT
OFF AND WE HEAR FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE STAFF AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THEY’RE
CONTINUING TO DO THE PHONE
CALLS.
WE APPRECIATE THE WHITE HOUSE
STAFF THAT ARE GIVING US
UPDATES.
THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GIVING THE UPDATES FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION AND HAVING
THE TOP PEOPLE ON THE PHONE WHO
CAN CUT THROUGH THE RED TAPE AND
BUREAUCRACY TO HEAR DIRECTLY
WHAT’S GOING ON IN THE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
STEVE: RIGHT.
>> I DO THIS REGULARLY WITH
SUPERINTENDENTS, MAYORS,
COUNTIES, HEALTH DIRECTORS, SO I
GET A FEEL FOR WHAT’S GOING ON
ACROSS MY STATE.
AND THAT’S PART OF HOW I HELP
CUT THROUGH THE RED TAPE AND
MAKE DECISIONS.
STEVE: SURE.
>> THAT’S NOT HAPPENING WITH
THIS WHITE HOUSE.
STEVE: IN FACT, I THINK IT WAS
LAST WEEK YOU WERE DRIVING
AROUND OMAHA IN YOUR CAR YOU
WERE LISTENING TO THE RADIO, AND
THERE IS A NEW FLASH ABOUT COVID
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE TOLD YOU
ABOUT.
WASN’T THERE?
>> YEAH.
THE WHOLE DECISION TO PAUSE J
AND J I HEARD ABOUT ON THE
RADIO.
AND I GUESS THE WHITE HOUSE I
GUESS THAT’S HOW THEY FOUND OUT
ABOUT IT, TOO.
BECAUSE APPARENTLY THEY DIDN’T
KNOW ABOUT IT.
THIS SHOWS THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS NOT DOING A FOOD JOB OF
COMMUNE INDICATING, EVEN
INTERNALLY WITH THEMSELVES IF
THE CDC IS MAKING THIS WHITE
HOUSE AND NOT TELLING THE WHITE
HOUSE OR GOVERNORS AND WE ARE
ALL CAUGHT BY SURPRISE.
IT REALLY NEEDS TO GET FIXED.
STEVE: SURE, BECAUSE I KNOW
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
THE PRESIDENT HAD SAID BECAUSE
EVERY STATE IS DIFFERENT, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY NEBRASKA
DIFFERENT THAN NEW YORK, THE
STATE GOVERNORS WOULD BE
ESSENTIALLY IN CHARGE OF
EXECUTING THE COVID STRATEGY.
BUT THIS WAY THE WAY IT’S GOING
RIGHT NOW, LESS CONTROL, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THEY ARE JUST TELLING
YOU, OKAY, THIS IS WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
>> WELL, TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THESE
EMERGENCIES ARE LOCALLY
EXECUTED, STATE MANAGED AND
LOCALLY SUPPORTED.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IS GETTING
SMALLER VIAL DOSES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO BIGGER VIAL
DOSES.
ONE EXAMPLE I THINK IF THE
PRESIDENT OR VICE PRESIDENT HEAR
DIRECTLY FROM GOVERNORS WHAT IS
NEEDED IN NEW YORK IS NOT
NECESSARILY NEEDED IN NEBRASKA
AND VICE VERSA THEY WOULD HAVE A
BETTER FEEL FOR HOW TO REALLY
MAKE SURE WE WERE CUSTOMIZING
THIS RESPONSE TO THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY RATHER THAN JUST MAYBE
ONE PART OF A COUNTRY OR ONE
SIZE FIT ALL ANSWER.
STEVE: LET’S SEE AFTER YOU GUYS
HAVE RAISED THIS CONCERN, LET’S
SEE IF THE VICE PRESIDENT AND/OR
THE PRESIDENT START PICKING UP
THE PHONE CALL AT 11:00 EVERY
TUESDAY MORNING.
GOVERNOR RICKETTS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US LIVE